way we're gonna be talking about no
man's sky and Alex you wrote something
kind of got a lot of us thinking or kind
of exaggerating out it didn't really get
moving no I'm kidding I'm just I'm honey
what why can't you sleep I just wrote
this thing I don't know what to think of
it yeah I actually saw you reading it
you just turn the only thing you said to
me was oh you've got a typo let me fix
you spelled mechanic like mech Nick Nick
if i recall click click uh anyway um
yeah so no mask I it's out in what a
week of riesling today L just ate I'll
just what is to the knife wait a second
yeah sec oh my god it's almost time I'm
supposed to be you're off to Europe yeah
yeah that's next week your ass yes yeah
but yes oh no my sky we've talked about
a lot but one of the looming questions
is like always kind of what we'll be
doing in it for a minute to minute and
we've kind of talked about that over a
few times like there's an economy to ALB
trying to improve your technology to
reach the center of universe after 30 or
40 something hours that one guy who
bought it ahead of time I think it took
him 35 I don't know if there's no that
he actually did it but yeah ms word Mike
yeah his word which you keep a good
segue isn't we're gonna talk about the
morality of no man's sky like basically
are you gonna be good or bad right
because there are choices like when I
first found out that you could be like a
space pirate like hell yes let me throw
out like put a parrot on my shoulder and
just zoom around the galaxy hijacking
people stealing people's stuff yeah like
yeah boarding the mainframe I'm trying
to think of like what like futuristic
Pirates would be doing would the parrot
also be futuristic yeah he's robotic a
cyborg pair okay so a spirit I feel much
better about this whole thing I was
worried for his well-being at the pretty
sure parents can't live in space so you
know it's a vacuum up there yeah but
basically it sound like it's such a big
universe right like where the odds of us
actually run against is another person's
like one in a hundred thousand hey isn't
that right even it's way lower than that
for really from the math I did it could
be different than they they could be
doing some trickery to get people in
with you but it's like I want I did the
math and to have a one-percent chance of
any two people being on the same planet
you would have
have like 300 million people playing at
the same time so that's like miniscule
chance the auras not even 300 million
people on earth she's saying I should
play the lotto instead of trying to find
someone else in no man's sky exactly I'm
waiting for that one comment that
actually thinks I was serious someone
thought i was serious man thought the
Eiffel Towers in Germany oh they
insulted the American education system I
don't know where they're from but I
guess probably france a sense of humor
so yeah but they're there are more than
I think they're mine 300 people in the
world but with that big of a universe
and like this many like the plethora of
ways you could spend your time or is it
gonna be like Grand Theft Auto where
you're just using it as a power fantasy
and kind of except like getting some
inner rage out or are you gonna be
trying to actually preserve it and like
be a good person like you might in mass
effect like a Paragon route right and i
think the probably one of the most
interesting parts of this is that they
say that the Universe to an extent is
going to be permanent so you can screw
up a planet bad enough that it's saved
to the server and there's like I really
can't think of another game that is like
that that has a universe that persistent
um that is shared among you know many
players minecraft I mean you can also
just restart this like make another
server though right like not if you
believe in that one server you play
minecraft ISM one server dude just
that's it that's it what's her
background yeah because that's I don't I
still don't even understand fully I
understand aren't like how the algorithm
works for them to create this universe I
don't get how that's gonna work in
retrospect and save everything but at
what point do you actually just start
caring about this universe when it's so
massive and how do you feel like you're
making an impact and then that was your
question if you don't feel like you're
making an impact why would you be good
right and if the only way you can make
an impact is by you know blowing up half
a planet then you know is that something
that we want to do yes no like I i I've
told people like my intent I've
expressed my intentions if I can create
some sort of Death Star I will in real
life yeah my maniacal intentions are
getting megamo megalomaniacal Danakil
let's go there yeah into space I'm just
going to destroy you
there's been AI and me lately uh huh I'm
not having it it's the biggest planet I
gotta take it down bullying everyone
else I think the biggest one yeah um
it's not even in our solar system how
many planets what target all [ __ ]
anywhere um but yeah like what what's to
stop someone from just pointing like
Grand Theft Auto like I would and at a
certain point how or is it actually
gonna affect the universe there's so
many unknowns with this game because
it's so big it's hard to wrap our minds
around lights it's a galaxy right now
the universe right and I mean like it is
a game right like it's fine for people
to have fun and go blow stuff up but i
think the the thing that makes this more
complicated is there are creatures in
this universe that only exist on like
one in a hundred million planets like
they're each creature you come across is
procedurally generated but there but
there are levels of uniqueness and
interest like there are more interesting
characters than others like you or
creatures than others you will come
across utopian civilizations may be and
what if a person rolls up to one of
these utopian civilizations to decide
that it's sighing and wrong yeah and
just blows it up yeah save to the server
two things how awesome would be if you
come across a planet with humans or some
similar intelligent sentient life and be
how much would that affect your like
your moral compass because if I'm just
going to destroy this for like a thing
and every all of its family members in
its planet I don't I don't care no I'll
probably like I'm a carnivore I'll eat
it and I'm not a vegetarian or vegan in
real life my character is gonna be a
vegan space pirate and that's okay
that's different but yeah if you come
across like how do you actually care
about these animals if like a they're
just animals but also be this is like no
one else in the world sees this animal
except for you like chances are like us
again how does how do you weigh the
population people number of people
playing the game with like who's
actually also seeing this yeah like my
personal thoughts on this is it'll
probably be easier for me personally to
preserve creature or it'll be more
likely that all preserved creatures who
look like humans like who interacts with
me in a certain way that is human-like
did the biggest threat yeah that is true
yeah take him down I would love if we
got the center of the universe and just
like punish the people who were bad yeah
that'd be awesome right how do you plan
on playing this game I
I like to think that I'll just be as you
all just going around you know making
sure we're keeping track of things that
I see that are cool but i'm probably
going to end up you know blown up space
stations and rolling around as a space
pirate makes ya pop yeah what about you
I really want to do a lot of flight an
exploration like in the you know the
outer space I don't think I'll be able
to do a lot of that because I'm also
reviewing this game there's a lot to do
I'm terrified of reviewing this game
mm-hmm but uh yeah I don't I I guess I
don't put too much stock into how I'm
going to feel about the decisions I make
in regards to affecting life or other
people but we'll see maybe it'll shift
yeah I plan on like I said being bed I'm
just gonna jump it like San Andreas and
kind of mess stuff up which it just begs
a question like how good do I think the
rest of the universe is and how much
punishment do I think it deserves from
my standpoint from my solipsistic
standpoint as a planet destroying vegan
space pirate with robotic parrot I've
already got this all figured out the
know me like I use his name what's the
name the universe has original sin you
have to punish it for its original sin
uh sorry your name thing derailed me
captain cyber jim g ym no no no no I
know like you know g ym yeah she's gonna
be ripped yeah i ripped a vegan space
pirate um no like that's how there's so
many unknowns of this game like again I
it's huge but how do we actually look at
it and how do we say like how do we like
affect this world and write that big and
I guess that's kind of affecting cuz of
san andreas and los santos or like these
like these actual contain environments
that you can see how your you don't
really affect the world in Grand Theft
Auto but like in mass effect that's uh
there's a fair number of planets you can
explore it's not this like the scope of
no man's sky but you're actually still
you know certain people won't make it to
Mass Effect 3 certain people won't even
make it through to how do you make those
decisions because it's a smaller cast
you actually care about them in this I
just feel like I'm not going to care
about anybody because I know there they
might be expendable because there's not
that much substance and I haven't played
the game very few people have but
house I can affect my decisions I don't
know it might all feel meaningless yeah
and I think there's a strange balancing
act there between what the developers
trying to do to make the world the
world's that many many worlds matter but
also just the sheer immensity of the of
the universe like you're you guys were
saying how do you make this stuff matter
how do you know why would you ever care
about one animal that you come across on
it on a planet when there are you know
an uncountable number of animals on
other planets yeah i mean the begs a
question like is any of this there's any
assessment or any of this matter how do
you make a game that big and actually
find meaning in it that's like I think
that's why everybody so curious but no
man's sky because um like if I could
explore the universe I probably wouldn't
care about like at you two what no you
know I wouldn't blame you i'd be good
I'd be happy to see you go honestly
close friends are only like a matter of
relativity yes like a more you travel
the more you explore the last minute I'm
gonna text you guys and see how you're
feeling unless I'm gonna open up to you
but snapchat still nothing yeah step off
to go snack me and uh me and I don't
have a name for the parrot yet either
hopefully better at this in a Groucho
there you go alright Jim and Groucho no
captain cyber gym and Groucho yeah it's
gonna be a matter of yeah substance how
do you find that in this world as their
substance to be found at a certain point
is the size of it kind of Trump yeah the
meaning you find in it do you guys care
about getting to the center of the
universe no no if you maybe the game
will make me care I mean yeah hello yeah
what I understand is like are you never
interrupted by like a an event that kind
of prods you'd to like want to do one
thing or another like that's what I
really want to know if this is just like
just go do whatever that's gonna be
super hard for me to like feel great
about continuing to do you know to do
because if I'm not working towards
something and if that something is only
getting to the center of the galaxy
thanks have you read anything about what
the leaker has been saying not really I
only looked at one of his gameplay close
so I was about a half hour long and i
clicked around it and minute to minute
he was doing the exact same thing yeah
just pointing his laser at rocks he has
he didn't spoil anything but he did say
that
is a little bit of that at least this
sort of direction yeah I feel like there
has to be yeah it has to be right well
the reason I wanna play no man's sky is
the same reason I played like Skyrim for
so long it was that just exploring this
world but that even that that was a
contain world's a singular experience
but there are like story threads going
through it whereas it doesn't seem like
that's gonna happen here the stories you
find are the ones you create yourself
which is very appealing well I don't
know that that's how I'm taking right
now it's just such a weird case and I'm
I'm excited for it to release just so we
can like know what the hell it is like
and I come in and ask about its exact
same conversation on the giant bombcast
is it like that's what it boils down to
be I just want to know what it is it's
curiosity at this period yeah if it's
great then awesome I'd maybe will be if
it's not then I don't know it's just
been you know like it's been hyped a lot
because it was such a weird it could be
like like a new benchmark for how things
like this are created but how much is
there going to be like how longevity and
you know reaching the center of the
universe like might be the goal but is
it worth taking the time to get through
yeah I mean in something that I've been
saying since it was announced is if it
was Proteus in space and they positioned
it as such I would be totally into it
but they've been hiding his game up and
talking about it and trying to put to
rest the whole the questions about his
gameplay and stuff that I think that for
one thing they'll never be able to
fulfill expectations for this and for
another I think they've gone like they
they just stopped stressing the
discovery aspect of it yeah so I don't
know yeah well anyway this is officially
I think the last time we're gonna talk
about no man's sky on the lobby before
it's outright it all comes out tuesday
but i don't think reviews are gonna be
up then it's it's so doubtful yeah okay
well likely aside from like when we get
to talk to you about the review i think
this is the last time we have to fit no
man's sky into it which is nice I feel
like I kind of want like I really want
to get into this game like I need an
outfit to wear when I'm playing it's
like an be cyber gym a snuggie Oh like
Oh robust I thought you meant something
comfortable like a catheter and a
snuggie yeah no okay no six pack of high
knees I know Takata is yeah I mean I'm
zorno all has the hybrid cyber gym and
Groucho super in one
doing it right but anyway a holy crap
that is no man's sky will you be good or
bad let us know in the comments below
the game comes out next week finally
depending on when you're watching this
video if you're watching alive then yeah
next week we'll talk about it more on
the lobby when we finally get to review
it but yeah